and we've got some breaking news here
and at Sky News and charges against Alex
Baldwin have been dropped to Helena
Hutchins of course died after being hit
by a live round which was in a prop gun
while they were filming the film star
Alec Baldwin of course had pled not
guilty to two counts of involuntary
manslaughter his lawyers have just
released a statement that's Luke niecos
and Alex Spiro
um they are saying that the criminal
charges have been dropped we are pleased
with the decision to dismiss the case
against Alec Baldwin and we encourage a
proper investigation into the facts and
circumstances of this tragic accident
and those pictures on your screen of her
director Helena Hutchins there